live-action Fullmetal Alchemist
literally broke me
character writing things did not go
according to plan it's hard to even know
where to begin with this one let me give
you a frim of reference here as I am
writing and record
cost days ago and while I did do some
top secret office remodeling in that
time I really just spent this entire
time trying to come up with a way to
talk about this movie usually for me I
go to watch the movie then I Rise then I
record the next day but not here not
with this monstrosity so strap
yourselves in and strap on folks because
whether you like it or not we are going
on Netflix's wild ride with Full Metal
Alchemist the final Alchemy which is
just the weirdest I don't like the title
so how does the final movie in this
live-action Trilogy stack up to the rest
well if it wasn't obvious by my
incoherent ramblings earlier it's the
worst one oh boy is it ever the worst
one which is not something I thought was
even possible like the first two
especially movie one
said a remarkably low bar but somehow
this movie exceeds or rather
anti-exceeds pretty much every
expectation I had going into this gone
are the days of laughing along with the
wackiness of it all here in its place is
a truly boring poorly made boring and
outright unenjoyable not to mention
boring movie but we will get to all of
that in due time so for now let's uh
let's dive in the movie opens up with
our good friend ho ho being robbed in
his travels standard manga fair so far
except oh look at that it's Izumi and
her husband pivotal characters that have
up until now just been completely
ignored and it's clear to me that this
entire opening section was the
screenwriter suddenly realizing that
wait we're missing like several of the
human sacrifices for the final ARCA oh
because izumi's introduction is about as
unceremonious as it could get she pops
up on screen punches a bad guy and then
we basically haircut the HoHo entering
her kinky by force and fixing her uterus
or something I I don't know then as soon
as we're done with that character
introduction we are right back to where
we left off last movie and of course
just as one would expect Envy spans
about
0.01 seconds in his lizard form before
quickly reverting to his human form
Gotta Give it to Envy they are truly
budget-minded here the movie studio
thanks him for his contributions this
entire section is really an immediate
red flag that somehow Despite All Odds
the CG in this movie is even worse than
what came before all of the scenes
inside gluttony's stomach are against a
plain dark background and despite that
simple background the green screen work
is still remarkably atrocious and
absolutely noticeable the entire time
meanwhile Alan gluttony go to Father for
reasons and Scar and may follow them for
equally real and valid reasons I guess
honestly the entire first 15 minutes is
the script desperately scrambling to
move chess pieces to the places they
need to be to tell the story of Briggs
and the Day of Reckoning Izumi being
introduced Al and Co shuffling after
father Mustang very quickly being
confronted by wrath it's all just one
big sprint to get characters where they
need to be and you know it's almost like
I talked about this problem last video
Fullmetal Alchemist is one big long
story with no individual Arc so the
thought of splitting it not just into
three parts but segregating its
disparate elements in an attempt to tell
the story in arcs is just Rife for
failure and contradiction but the
baffling part is even with how bad this
approaches this movie manages to make
things even worse with how quickly it's
forced to speed through everything
nothing is given Breathing Room the
entire thing feels like an any percent
out of bounds speedrun of Full Metal
Alchemist but no longer in a fun way
it's just one long chain of story beat
happens and then yada yada and then the
next story beat happens over and over
and over and over again until it's two
hour run time has expired and you are
left questioning your sanity sitting
there in your couch contemplating the
meaning of your very existence sorry
where was I oh yeah so now fear the
power of gluttony spitting the cast out
with the most incredible and convincing
CGI I have ever seen might I add
everyone is in Father's throne room
expositing at one another we get all the
Beats we expect father realizing Ed is
ho ho son father deleting everyone's
Alchemy powers and so on so forth but
then once again the script remembers
that it is still missing an element of
the end and introduces us to the one and
only greed except in this version of
course great has never ever been seen
before or mentioned up until now so how
do they go about reconciling that with
his introduction well that's the neat
part they don't do anything father oozes
out some McDonald's sweet and sour sauce
from his head drops it in Ling's
conveniently plays cut and then greed
just pops up like hey guys it's me yeah
I used to exist off-screen but now I'm
here give me your body and thus greatly
is born and oh man let me tell you the
amount of cringe anime guy vibes from
greed are immense Dude Looks like he's
part of one of those Tick-Tock cringe
compilations and also am I going insane
does Ling have freckles now does greed
carry with him the Evangelical power of
freckles what are the implications of
this did I miss some deep record oh no
I'm about to lose my mind a little and
we're only 20 minutes into the movie
ever late to the party skyra May show up
and perform an hilariously poor attempt
at saving the day scar does his best
beerus impression and may is promptly
dispatched by a single unconvincing
punch from gluttony incredible work
folks scar decides to retreat and uses
Al's head to ignite the dust in the air
via a spark oh okay this one actually
breaks my brain like for one what but
like even setting aside how insane that
is doesn't scar know Alchemy we've seen
him blow up before so why why I
just I don't understand I'm moving on
whatever Flash over to Izumi at her meat
shop where she is now on a phone call
with Ed yeah didn't you know she's Ed
and Al's teacher we've established this
before right wink wink come on you've
watched the anime this entire movie
depends on you watching the anime it
lets the anime do narrative heavy
lifting it's a joke I hate this movie I
will say at least that once again the
casting and costume design Remains the
only steadfast element of these films
Izumi looks exactly like you would want
to look in a live action adaptation of a
character while also somehow not looking
totally silly or cartoonish it's really
hard to stress how much of a diamond in
the rough these costume designs are the
costume designer of this Trilogy is
nishihara who was probably plucked from
her work on a live-action play
adaptation of Naruto titled live
spectacle Naruto song of the Akatsuki
and from what I've seen while I can't
say much in the story or acting one of
the main consensuses is that the
classroom designs for this play are
similarly the overwhelming highlight of
its production from what I can tell they
haven't done any more costume design
Works since these movies but I can't
help but think that they have a
particular knack for adapting these
wacky anime designs into live action in
both a convincing and faithful Manner
and so I would definitely be interested
in seeing their work on a more competent
production in the future anywho
literally one scene after chatting with
Izumi in Central City surprise Ed Scar
and Co are now in Briggs and have
uncovered Scar's brother's secret
Alchemy notes no I am not kidding they
really did just press the fast forward
button on like seven volumes of content
but you must understand guys we don't
have time we must quickly get over this
silly little plot point and get to the
real meat of this section and that is
that is the crew sit down and enjoy a
nice meal of canned oil bean soup okay
actually that's pretty damn funny shout
out to the guy who made that in the
props game I am now officially starting
my Bean Soup company click the Subscribe
button to invest with their stomachs
full of totaling up Mark grinded boiled
bean soup they decipher the notes in a
whopping half a second and set off to
the harsh land of Briggs to stop the
final point or should I say
transmutation circle it's at this point
we are once again introduced to some new
lovely character designs in the form of
Buccaneer and Olivier Armstrong these
designs really remain on point and it
drives me crazy that such talent was
wasted on such shite movies but none of
that actual critique and critical
thinking is important what is important
is that the live action Ed is clearly
literally medically blind in fact let's
play a game here this is the silhouette
that Ed sees approaching him in the
snowstorm let's all guess what we think
this is is it a the Abominable Snowman
is it B the Grinch of whom Stole
Christmas or C very clearly a tall man
with a mohawk and prosthetic arm aha
trick question the answer is d a a bear
but what come on
in the history of all Evolution on
biology has any bear ever looked like
that like I get it it's a snowman so
it's a bit hard to see but a silhouette
is very clearly visible do you know what
a bear looks like Ed it looks like this
this is what a bear looks like Ed do you
see a prosthetic arm someone bring me
back to reality please after a brief
stint of man Skyrim covering the double
secret of his brother's notes to the
tune of some extremely James Bond
sounding music We Are unceremoniously
introduced to the one and only sloth
it was at this point I realized that
this movie CG had transcended bad the CG
work for sloth goes so far past bad CG
that it goes even Beyond wrapping around
to so bad it's good and transcends all
the way back to so bad it's bad again
there is no shot of him in this entire
movie's run time that doesn't look like
complete ass I am 99.9 sure that they
rip the skin texture from a PS2 game
thankfully we don't have to look at him
for too long because our good friend
Armstrong goes full cartoon mode and
shoves him out the door while literally
peeking out the top of a tank and with
that we are officially back to the being
100 faithful to the anime is not always
a good thing conversation of the last
video oh my God having said that though
at least this sequence was fun in a
goofy sort of way like yes it is
incredibly stupid and impossible to take
seriously but as I was soon to find
unlike the rest of this movie I at least
got to laugh at this scene in an ironic
sort of way unfortunately it's at this
point only 40 minutes into the film at
which the last breaths of any sort of
entertainment are thrown out the window
from this point on all the chess pieces
are in place and it is a scene by scene
loose adaptation of the anime story as
you know it some things are trimmed
everything happens at four times speed
and nothing lands I really mean that I
want to emphasize that nothing lands in
this movie and it's all just so
incredibly boring it's so insanely
boring like the greatest sin of the
first two movies is that they were often
just chock full of long stretches where
nothing fun interesting or entertaining
in the slightest happens and apparently
this movie script decided that those
elements were actually the trilogy's
strong longest points because it goes
all in on this idea whatever you could
possibly imagine the remaining 80
minutes of run time could look like that
is in fact exactly what this is you
nailed it fantastic great job gold star
and legitimately it left me sitting here
thinking well what is even to be talked
about here this movie brought me to a
complete existential questioning of my
value of reviews and videos of this
nature to begin with like yes I could
sit here and go through the blow by blow
of so much of the rest of this talk more
about cringy windy flirting how despite
a complete lack of character Armstrong
remains that or recant the bits
with Ho-Ho living his life with Al for a
bit before launching into a 10 minute
long flashback about the dwarf in a
flask I could talk about how Salem is
revealed as pride in a completely
unceremonious way without any actual
build up to the mystery leading to the
biggest dropped ball in this entire
Trilogy prior to getting captured
extremely easily with Al the siege of
Central City the Armstrong versus sloth
situation zombies the brutal owning of
Mustang vs Henry wrath vs Ling etc
etc
etc I think the reflective point I'm
trying to make might be clear by now
there is nothing more worth to talk
about here it is all the same there is
absolutely nothing of value to be
extracted from talking more about this
movie in series as a whole and that's
exactly what I spent almost an entire
week straight grappling with here as I
alluded to at the beginning of this very
video this final installment in an
already abysmal Trilogy has brought me
to my own door of Truth it really leads
me to contemplate the very nature of
reviews and video essays like this is
the actual value some sort of legitimate
Insight reviewers and SCS bring to the
table to help the Layman appreciate and
understand works of fiction I mean I've
certainly read countless books on the
fundamentals and deep depths of
Storytelling screenplay writing blocking
lighting whatever but if that is the
value of these videos then there is
indeed nothing left to be said here
because there is nothing to extract no
deeper meaning to design no lessons or
critiques to be had that I didn't
already discuss in detail in the last
video but perhaps I'm wrong maybe the
value of these videos is simply as a
form of supplementary content folks
consume a piece of media they enjoyed
and resonated with and run to YouTube to
find other folks talk about in detail I
think that is the value of a lot of
video essays even the ones that purport
to have deeper meaning but again if that
is the case I'm right back to the
well-being drive for this movie the
movie adds absolutely nothing of value
that isn't already existent in the
original manga or anime so what is left
to say perhaps I thought to myself for a
while I could just make the video Simply
a fun little ROM through the many many
failings of the movie giggle along with
the audience as we both point and laugh
together at the complete failing of
Cinema and storytelling that is this
movie there's certainly plenty more that
I didn't get to I haven't even mentioned
things like the CG on the dwarf's full
form Mustang continually forgetting that
he is meant to be blind the movie still
attempted to do a greed sacrifice even
though we've spent less than 10 minutes
total with the character I mean the list
goes on but is that actually fun at a
certain point I can only spend so long
pointing and laughing before it loses
its worth before it starts to feel
masochistic not to mention deeply
mean-spirited towards the folks who no
doubt worked tirelessly for many years
to bring these movies to our screens at
a certain point I think the fun in that
sort of thing evaporates into
nothingness so then at the end of this
six hour Trilogy having known long ago
that these movies are bad the greater
question remains how do I cover this how
do I cover this final ultimately
worthless finale what is the core value
of my videos well I think after a lot of
thinking the answer I've come to is that
in order to stay true to the core goals
of this channel to deliver you all video
those that cover media and dive into
them analytically and glean elements of
art critique and heart from them I have
to do something I've never really done
before I have to stop here the idea of
covering half of a movie in the finale
of a Trilogy no less is definitely one
of the weirdest things I've ever done on
this channel but I think almost
counter-intuitively this sort of thing
delivers a lot more introspective value
than another 30 minutes of laughing and
pointing at bad CG Clips could ever
offer I think there is a real value in
contemplating when to stop consuming
something so so so very often now the
prevailing form of content you see
online is negative content that focuses
on making fun of bad media people who
hate watch bad anime and post about how
bad it is online content farming outrage
videos from twitch drama people who have
made entire careers out of stirring the
pot and preying on the negative aspects
of Art and human connection negativity
plays better than almost anything else
hate generates way more response than
love every social media website
resistance not only knows this but
operates with that very motto at its
very core you can't go and inch in any
direction without finding a hot take
from someone online that brings
absolutely no value to the conversation
and maybe all of this is just human
nature but I think it's worth rebelling
against I think there's so much more
value out there to be explored so much
more deeply impactful art to look into
and experience rather than angrily point
and laugh at the failures of art along
the way for every Angry Birds movie
there is an HBO's The Last of Us for
every Emoji Movie there is a Wally for
every morbius there is an everything
everywhere all at once the depths of
human creativity are as best as we can
tell completely endless I mentioned in
my main Fullmetal Alchemist video that
the thought of the series having sat
behind me for years without me knowing
how special it truly was really struck a
chord with me and that thought works
extremely well in contrast to this movie
If I Only Have One Life to Live if we
only have one life to live and there is
already a near infinite amount of
genuinely incredible Works to both
consume and talk about how can we in our
right Minds spend more time echoing on
about this film or anything else being
so terrible that it's funny so for the
conclusion of this video I'm gonna take
some notes from the last piece of
legitimate art that touched me I am
stealing a move from Fullmetal Alchemist
greed this insane move simply stopping
this review halfway into the movie is my
final Rebellion against the concept of
hate watching itself I'm cutting it here
and I'm going to encourage anyone that
made it this far into this video to go
consume some new art that you enjoy pick
up that manga you've been thinking about
reading go watch that movie with your
friend that they've been recommending
you to watch relentlessly for years now
hell go make some art yourself take the
30 minutes of making fun of this shitty
movie that you could have saved and make
something of it seize the day I'm gonna
do the same maybe spend some time with
my family and the next time you see me
I'll be talking about some New pieces of
art that will have no doubt given me
additional insight into the world we
live in but until then I've been totally
not mark this has been a weird one but
as always thank you so much for watching
foreign
[Music]